my parents Tom and Judy met in college
got married at age 23 and have been
together ever since
so I guess I thought that's how the
formula worked you find someone young
plug in that unknown variable as X and
out spits Y happily ever after so given
that I just turned 30 this month I
thought I'd have it all figured out by
now I come home for the holidays and I
have one brother
Yates that's married with two kids and
another brother Pierce that's married
with two kids and six weddings scheduled
for this year and I'm feeling a small
amount of panic mounting or
claustrophobia like the walls of my
youth or uterus are closing in on me now
this isn't a pity party I'm a smart
successful woman I'm sophisticated yet
scrappy when I need to be I'm
well-connected but don't take myself too
seriously and I'm by no means trying to
sell myself here the truth is I've been
dating ever since the fifth grade why
haven't I figured this all out yet
I asked the person who knows me best
what my greatest weakness is and my mom
replied you live in denial that choices
must be made and she's right but
choosing a life partner it's a pretty
daunting choice
I mean maybe Cinderella only married
Prince Charming because she didn't meet
Prince Eric first look at that stud
muffin I decided to dive into the
research and I stumbled upon the
Stanford marshmallow experiment in this
study if a kid can resist the smaller
prize one marshmallow he'll get a bigger
reward later two marshmallows all I'm
saying is I'm holding out for my two
marshmallows
here's how I break down my dating
prospects on the x-axis I measure
long-term viability which I call the
Penguins access because penguins made
for life is this guy good to bring home
to the parents total penguin on the
y-axis I made ho ho ho on the y-axis I
measure how excited I am about someone
so I call that the butterflies axis do I
get nervous every time I send and
receive a text definite butterflies so
as previewed I'm a teacher I want to
fill this graph with examples like US
presidents bottom right quadrant you'd
have someone whose high penguin below
butterflies danger I might be settling
Jimmy Carter
really nice guy but
in the top left quadrant you'd have
someone who's high butterflies below
penguin fun but maybe not marriage
material bottom left quadrant not a
penguin and no butterfly as well that's
just wasting my time but I couldn't
think of a US president who's both and I
realized am i being unrealistic if I
wait and wait for this elusive top right
quadrant - marshmallow kind of man I
needed some answers so I set up focus
groups filled with my single friends
and in these conversations I learned
that Stanford grad students think about
this question a lot
whereas I make graphs some of my friends
make spreadsheets one of my female
friends Becca made what she called a
life partner matrix where she breaks
down what she's looking for into three
categories
emotional intellectual and physical she
further broke down each piece of this
pie into four slices for example for the
emotional connection
does he love my shortcomings is he
reciprocally vulnerable do we argue
fairly and lovingly in these focus
groups my friends also shared just how
difficult their dating journeys have
been one of my gay friends on hell
shared how he was making out with a guy
at a club only to realize that guy while
kissing him still had his eyes open and
was looking over on his shoulder
checking out all the other guys in the
room another friend Marco even made a
consulting slide deck analyzing his lack
of dating success on OkCupid
so
maybe I have nerdy friends may be
talking to Stanford grad student doesn't
accurately represent the population but
I realized my research was flawed if I
wanted to figure out how to choose a
life partner I needed to talk to my
friends in committed relationships so I
sent them a survey and asked one simple
question how did you choose your partner
here are three of my favorite responses
there was never a lightning bolt moment
per se just a gradual increase of
connection and affection a couple of
months in I realized I had something to
lose if we broke up we met on a road
trip and got stuck in horrendous traffic
and I remember it is the best drive of
my life I think I fell in love with him
that day I chose my partner by following
my heart and my gut I thought about how
to get her when we were single I thought
about how to keep her when we were
dating and now I think about how to make
her happy and build a life together now
that we are married isn't that something
in my research I talked to a guy named
Nate Bagley who traveled the country
interviewing married couples his
takeaway don't settle for mediocre love
epic love exists and he's seen it so I
reached out and asked if I could
interview him over Skype and in that
conversation
Nate Bagley said to me okay Jackie you
got five great guys in front of you
who's the right choice so I said the one
who inspires me to be my best self and
he said okay they all do that who's the
right choice
so I said the one who makes me laugh the
hardest and he said okay they're all
hilarious
who's the right choice so I said I come
home from a business trip who's the
first person I want to see and he said
okay you want to see all of them who's
the right choice and flustered
I said Nate I don't know how to choose
where is this going
he said to me Jackie
the right choice is the one you choose
and you make it right and if you're not
in a place to make that kind of
commitment you just might miss some
amazing candidates in January I was
dating a really nice guy coincidentally
named Nathan total penguin but after a
couple months I abandon ship I wasn't
prepared to commit so I ended it and
talking to Nate Bagley I realized I'm
the person at the club kissing with
their eyes open constantly looking over
someone's shoulder for what's better
so I said to Nate Bagley wait you said
don't settle for mediocre love epic love
exists that's what I'm waiting for
and he said Jackie epic love isn't this
innate thing epic love is the work you
both put in to make it better than
yesterday that's epic here I was so
afraid of settling for one marshmallow
and I realized there's a difference
between settling and settling in
settling in means loving someone for
their shortcomings closing your eyes
during the kiss and working every day at
being a better partner in this team the
takeaway here is choose who you love and
love who
choose writing this talk has changed
everything for me because after all the
research the focus groups the interviews
turns out all the work had to be done
here internally not externally the day
after I broke up with Nathan the penguin
he came over and he said to me I don't
accept your resignation and I thought
whoa that's pretty epic is this penguin
giving me butterflies so I withdrew my
resignation no I don't know if Nathan is
my two marshmallow man but I'm gonna
find out because this time I'm going
all-in
thank you